how's it going everyone today we're
going on a bit of an adventure and we're
going to look at two different integrals
from i guess two ends of the
mathematical spectrum
and at two vastly different price points
we're going to compare them and see
which one
gives the better experience now i'm not
alone in doing this i've enlisted the
help of someone with very fine taste in
mathematics
and that's jens from the channel
flammable maths
now jens is a seasoned integral taster
so he is going to walk us through
today's delicacy
an integral which requires complex
analysis
to start with though i'm going to walk
us through today's budget item
and it's an essential tool in the
toolbox of any budding mathematician
today i'm going to be integrating
everybody's friend
e to the x now i'm working at what is
essentially a poor man's version of a
blackboard today it's a sticker on a
wall with lots of bubbles
but you get what you pay for i guess now
e to the x
is a function that was almost designed
to be integrated
or to be more in particular designed to
be differentiated
e to the x is a creation of
mathematicians
we made e to the x because we wanted a
function
call it y where the slope of y at every
point
was equal to the function itself
now this is satisfied if y does equal
e to the x
we can have a look at how y or e to the
x
would be constructed and let's first
think about where it would start
so if we wanted to start at x equals
zero then this is e to the zero which
is one so y at that point is going to be
equal
to one all right so let's write down
and construct our y of x
we know it starts at one and we know
that the derivative of it
d y d x
is going to always be equal to the
function itself so that's going to have
to
start with a 1 as well now this is also
the derivative of this and we know that
for a 1 to be in a derivative it means
there must have been at least one
you know function of x in the
function itself so if we have one plus x
that will correctly give
us the derivative one but in doing that
these are no longer equal anymore so
we've got to make them equal let's
add that x down here as well and that
gives us the same problem
to have an x and the derivative of a
function
there must have been at least an x
squared power
in the function itself in fact it would
have had to be x squared over 2
to give us this derivative but you know
we
need to keep these equal to each other
so we're going to have to add that term
here as well
we seem to be going around in circles a
little bit
then this is going to keep going on like
this you might
recognize the pattern to actually be
x to the n over n
factorial where for example here n was 2
this is 2 factorial it's just 2 and
we've got the squared power at the top
and so this here and
this keeps going this is going to be
our series representation of the
function
e to the x that's what is equal to
now you might be familiar with e the
number as being like 2.7
something that pops out of here 2
if we were to set e to the x with
x equal to 1. if x is equal to one
this is just e
and if that's going to be always a one
this would be a one here
this would be one squared over two
that'll be a half
and so that's already 2.5 there and each
of these
smaller terms are gonna you know get to
be very small numbers we're going to
keep adding on successively smaller
amounts
until it you know gets to around the
value of
2.7 blah blah blah blah all right and
that's the familiar face of e that you
might have seen before
this is a way of writing it out that
shows you in a way how
e came to be it was designed so that the
derivative
of the function was always going to be
the function itself
using the property of e to the x that we
just went through
we can write down its integral as e to
the x
plus our boy c now if you've done almost
any integration at all you'll remember
or you'll recognize what c is he's our
friend that we just have to remember
not to leave behind he's the constant of
integration
and he's there because you know he
doesn't depend on x
so the derivative of the c would have
been zero
and so it's very possible that there
could have been some constant here
where when differentiated it disappears
so we've
got to leave that there just in case but
this is our integral
pretty basic pretty intuitive and very
widely useful
so when tasting integrals we've got to
consider multiple things such as the
value the complexity
the beauty of the integral and you know
its usefulness
and i'd say this one scores pretty
highly i i think it's
you know got a big bang for your buck
you're getting a lot of value out of
this you can use this integral in a lot
of places it'll
make math pretty simple for you and it's
pretty elegant as well so i'm looking
forward to seeing what our next integral
looks like and how it can
rival this one here but let's hear from
jens on that one
good morning fellow shrimps thanks to
toby for inviting me to a little
show right here but toby are you are you
serious
that's not what i signed up for
take a look at that i i can't integrate
this i
i i don't know what i feel worthy i
physically can't integrate this function
right here
what the hell do you think you are
giving me here i'm out
so my manager just talked to me and he
told me if i don't integrate this
function then i'm
gonna be fired so i guess i have no
chance
right here we are going to give this
thing right here short using
complex analysis complex analysis today
because that's just
really elegant and you see that's the
function and we are going to call this
thing
i for integral you can also call it j
for ends i
i really don't care or t for toby and at
first i would like to define
a complex function a complex valued
function we are going to call it f
of set and we are going to define it as
follows that's natural log of set
squared
over set squared plus one and if you
take a look at the denominator right
here
what is plus one that is nothing but
negative
i squared where i is the imaginary
constant and you see that's just a
difference of two squares and we can
factor it so that's quite easy
so we end up with natural log of set
over set plus i
times set minus i and
this denominator right here gives rise
to
two poles two singular poles at that so
where are our poles at they are part of
western euro
i know that but also
we can just take a look at here so poles
are just points where
our denominator would go to zero and our
function would explode to infinity you
could say
so that also means we have two poles set
one and two at the points
i and negative i so plus and minus i
and now we can take a look at the
contour because if you want to use the
residue theorem complex analysis
we would like to take a look at the
contour integral of this complex valued
function f offset
integrated with respect to set okay
that's cool but what does our contour
look like well
for this i would like to take a look at
the complex um plane
and just at the upper half so this makes
things easier
so why not take a look at a semicircle
in the upper half of the complex plane
but here's the thing we have a
singularity you could say
if we plug in zero into here in this
natural log of set this function would
explode to negative infinity
we don't want it so we have to get
around the singularity that's a branch
point so why not
construct a little semicircle around the
origin right here with a little radius
of
epsilon i don't care and our
outer semicircle has a radius of r so
this goes from
r and negative r right here to negative
epsilon
and epsilon because epsilon is just a
radius and
this thing right here is just the
contour c that's what we are going to
call it
and also our upper outer semicircle
is nothing but gamma we are going to
call it this and our inner semi-circle
is nothing but i don't know capital
lambda so that means our contour
integral right here consists of four
parts we have this
gamma integral and then also we have
this
lambda integral and also we have two
other integrals
one on the real axis so here we are
going to integrate with respect to set
but those are just running on the real
axis so we have
another integral running from negative r
to negative epsilon
f of x dx so just changing those
complex valued sets right here to just
re-evaluate x's
and also another integral from epsilon
to r of the same thing
f of x dx
but also like i said before we would
like to use the residue theorem
so those four parts added together are
equal to two times
pi times i times the sum of the residues
in this case but we only have to
consider one residue because our
contour plus has the residue of i in it
so this singular pole i so
set one right here the residue at the
point set one and we're going to
calculate it now
you might ask yourself now what the hell
is the residue at the point that being
equal to i
well we boys here at buzzfeed are going
to do that way
we do nothing but apply the limit when z
approaches i
to set minus i times f offset
but what exactly is f of step it's
nothing but the natural log
of set squared over set plus i
times set minus i and you see this is
going to cancel out
quite nicely that's why we factored it
in the first place and well
now we can just apply the limit without
any complications
so we have the natural log of i complex
number that's weird
squared over two times i because i plus
i is just two times i
you might ask yourself now what exactly
is the natural log of i well we can just
take a look at the complex plane for
that
so this right here is the complex plane
with this being the real x uh
with this being the real axis and this
being the imaginary axis
and where exactly is our point i it's
just up here
and if you take a look at the definition
of a complex
function set is nothing but r times e to
the i phi
whereas the length of our vector right
here in r2 you could say
and phi is just the angle enclosed by
this vector
and real axis so that means if we just
go up here to i
what's our angle well this is pi over 2
but now you could say what if we go
around this way once again and land here
this is just
5 times pi over 2 and again and again
with some k
times pi over 2 k of some integer number
well we are just going to take a look at
the principal front
right here being pi over 2. we're just
going to do that we are
not making it more complicated than it
already is and what exactly is our r
well it's just length of the vector but
i is on our unit circle so that means r
is nothing but
one so that also means that i is nothing
but
e to the i times pi over two and if we
apply the natural log
to both sides natural log of e to the
something is just
the something itself so i times pi over
2.
and here we go we are done and we can
plug this in so we end up with
i times pi over 2 but the whole thing
squared
over 2 times i and well i squared is
nothing but
negative 1 times pi squared
over 4 times 2 times i so this is 8
times i
and now we can just plug the value of
this residue into our
contour integral and then we are
basically done
so all i really did was just plug
everything
into what we have gathered before and
you might notice on this expression
right here our i is going to cancel out
so that makes it
real valued that's cool and our two and
one over eight
is going to cancel out somehow to one
over four
so we end up with this additive chunk
right here to be just negative
pi to the third power over four okay
that's cool and now i would like to take
a look at only this integral right here
so we are going to write it out
[Applause]
um okay we are going to end up with an
integral from negative r
to negative epsilon of natural log of x
squared over x squared plus one
integrated with respect to x
and well what we can do now we can just
introduce the substitution
so let x be equal to negative x or
negative u you can call it whatever you
want it's just a dummy variable
so what we want to do we want to let x
be equal to negative x
that also means that our dx is going to
be transformed
to negative dx and we can plug all of
this chunk in so what happens to our
upper and lower bound well they just
change signs to r and epsilon in this
case
so we have natural log of negative x
natural log of a negative number that's
weird once again
we're going to talk about this in a
minute over
well negative x squared is just x
squared it doesn't change
plus 1 negative dx
and now we can distribute this negative
sign into here to change the order of
integration
into the integral from epsilon to r of
the natural log
of negative x squared over x squared
plus one
dx and for this natural log of a
negative number i would once again just
like to take a look into the complex
plane
let's put it here so just like before we
have talked about
the vectors before so that being equal
to r times e to the i phi
and on the real axis our negative one
is right here so that means we are going
to go this way
and we are enclosing an angle of pi
in this case taking the principal branch
once again
and also it's lying on the unit circle
this negative one so our r is going to
be one
that also means that natural log of
negative x
is nothing but well we can use the
natural log property because this is
just negative 1
times x so turning is it into the
natural log of negative 1
plus the natural log of x and well
natural log of negative 1 in this case
so
negative 1 is nothing but e to the i
times pi
taking natural log on both sides
it's just i times pi it's as easy as it
is
so we end up with um i times pi
plus natural log of x and we can plug
this new information into here
so we end up with let's put this in the
box
the integral from epsilon to r of the
natural log
of x plus i times pi whole thing squared
over x squared plus one integrated with
respect to x
and you see we can just use the binomial
formula up here in the numerator to end
up with a final integral from epsilon to
r
of natural log of x whole thing squared
plus
and our natural log of x times i times
pi
and now i times pi squared this is just
negative pi
squared negative pi squared over
x squared plus 1 dx and
i'm going to write everything out and
i'll see you back in a second
so as you can see i just wrote
everything out nicely and
do not wonder about this expression that
was just the integral we had
derived a second ago but broken up into
three
different indications those are just
additive we can just break them up
and now i would like you guys to
consider something and kills
also the girls around here on this
channel
if we would just let epsilon go to zero
on the limit and r go to infinity in the
limit well that would just be our
original integral that we wanted to
evaluate
same thing here so we can add those two
together in a minute but what exactly
would happen to ex
for example to this gamma integral and
this lambda integral
well we are here at bus street you know
and we have a lot of money so the ad
revenue is falling from the sky
all day long but what we don't have is a
lot of time that's why we went to our
local complex analysis dealer you know
this guide is selling new lemmas and
theorems and stuff like this
and we bought a little dlc called
jordan's lemma
and we can use it on those two right
here all it really does is
to let the lambda integral go to zero in
the limit when epsilon approaches zero
and
if r approaches infinity gamma is also
going to zero so this makes things real
really easy and we are going to take the
limit on both sides now and see what we
get
so we end up with the limit as epsilon
goes to zero
and r goes to infinity of our contour
integral i'm going to write it like this
this is just um on this side right here
well this is just the limit of a
constant it doesn't affect our constants
so negative
pi to the third power over four being
equal to
this and that is going to vanish we can
add those two together and i want you
guys to notice if we
and girls to notice i'm so sorry this
needs to be politically correct no i
i have no idea but um if we let epsilon
approach zero and our infinity that's
just our original integral i
so we have 2 times i plus i times pi
and this one doesn't really concern us
we are just going to call it j now it
doesn't really matter
so this is just j like against the
mathematical mean guide is probably me
and also this integral negative pi
squared
times the integral from zero to infinity
of dx
over x squared plus one and you see this
right here is really easy to evaluate
this is just the inverse tangent
this integral right here
of x in the limits from zero to infinity
and well
inverse tangent of zero is just zero and
the inverse tangent when x approaches
infinity
is just pi over two so this is just pi
to the third power
over two so what do we have we have
negative pi to the third power over four
being equal to two times i
plus i times pi times j negative
pi to the third power over two and what
we can do we can add this expression on
both sides
so adding pi to the third power over two
also here pi to the third power over two
this is going to cancel out
and this thing right here is exactly
going to evaluate to
the positive term right here so you can
advance this reaction by two over two
and you immediately see where this comes
from so this is just pi to the third
power
over four equals to two times i plus i
times pi
times j and since two isn't equal to
zero you can prove this by using
piano axioms or something or you can
just rush the buzzfeed guy right here on
this
we can divide both sides by two so
this by two this is going to cancel out
this by two and if we divide this by two
this is just pi to the third power
over eight and you see the real part of
this
complex number so real part imaginary
part is just going to be
the value of our integral that we wanted
to evaluate so that also means
the real part of this contour integral
f offset d set contour integral
is nothing but pi to the third power
over eight
so if we just compare coefficients you
could say
and this is nothing but our
we are done my boys and girls and
everything else in between
the value of our nice little contour
integral right here is
pi to the third power over eight and
this thing is worth
a million bucks probably because it's
just so damn cool complex analysis
is awesome and if you didn't enjoy this
video please like and subscribe to
the shrimp and me i'm flammable math if
you didn't know already
and up until next video have a flammable
and
deepest day see ya
[Music]